remember when
Santa Maria's blood sulfur ball
said he had 1 wonderful idea
which was to refloat the 6th which was 1
and send people there from we can
because that's how it took away Zoe's vote.
wasn't great
it was wonderful,
wasn't it
that's the PP eh that's the PP
PP has nothing else
the PP has no ideology but that of the euro
the ideology of the euro they put eh
when they wake up they go to bed at night
instead of praying 1 Our Father
to the almighty pray to the euro
to the euro is true
it is true that later they will give
some stunned
to suicide in churches does not
but it is pure posturing and posturing to nothing else,
isn't it?
y y y a 1 le jode say this to him I tell him
do not think that you 1 stays at ease
saying this
because there are so many good people who vote for Pepe.
that these things often feel horrible to him
but it is the reality
it's the truth it's not my truth
it is the accomplished facts that